kidding aside of course president Harris
my name is Joe Biden I'm Joe Biden's
husband and I am communist running mate
[Music]
[Applause]
you all think I'm kidding don't you well
president Harris LED this effort
LED this effort I also want to thank my
buddy Kamala who I work for in uh up in
the white house last week president
Harris and I happy birthday a great
President we know your mom's always with
you
what's up humans another assorted life
creatures I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's May 22nd Monday May
22nd we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals if you'd like to join
us for a post game show where I answer
uncensored questions I listen to your
commentary and more please join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and I have to
tell you people we have a very dense
thick packed show a lot of paper a lot
of chances for paper cuts we're going
deep it's a deep dive I'm telling you
remember today May 22nd because this
week in American history will go down as
a big one because there is a lot of
political stuff happening as they say I
think you can sense at least one of them
has to do with that guy here in Florida
Mr Florida man Ron DeSantis himself but
today what we will be doing with the
program is unpacking what is a
conservative you know I often talk about
this sort of wide tent conservative
movement right you're going to have your
ex-libs your Libertarians you're going
to have your more social conservatives
but basically what I would say is you've
got sort of this big tense situation
that sometimes can feel a little tenuous
you have people that have definite
disagreements on things have
disagreements on things like abortion
you could take a guy like Rudy Giuliani
obviously a conservative but happens to
be pro-choice you could take a guy like
say a Mike Huckabee more on the
religious conservative side you could
take an ex-lib like me you could take
someone maybe a little more libertarian
like Joe Rogan but there's this crew of
people at this point that are coming
together out with Elon Musk in there as
well that are basically believing in
reality how about that so we always talk
about what is a one I'm in today we're
going to talk about what is a
conservative because I think if we can
set some parameters around that
not in the old way people used to talk
about conservatives you're very stuffy
and you only care about tax breaks but
if we can do it in a new school let's
conserve America let's conserve freedom
and individual rights and all of the
good stuff that has been so freaking
great here for 250 plus years I think we
can save the country I really do maybe
I'm just Juiced up because it's Monday I
don't know but let's see what happens
but the point is that uh when when you
start getting the Coalition of good
people fighting the machine the machine
fight fights back hard there's a lot of
evidence of that so we're going to get
to all of that before we do let me talk
about my Patriot Supply guys you know I
can't believe the dire headlines we're
facing in the world today ain't it the
truth everywhere you look things are
falling apart that's why the smartest
investment you can make right now is in
your family's food security the reality
is you might not be able to find food
when the next disaster strikes grocery
stores could be empty because roads will
be closed and trucks won't be able to
make deliveries probably not here in
Florida in other places when that
happens you need emergency food in full
Supply that's why I urge you to grab a
three-month emergency food kit for my
Patriot Supply the nation's largest
preparedness company when you order an a
you'll save 200 on each kit that you
need having these kits means your family
will stay fed While others stand in food
lines don't delay order your three-month
emergency food kit and save 200 bucks
per kit it's easy to order go to prepare
with reuben.com you'll get fast and free
shipping too do this today or you will
regret it tomorrow prepare with
reuben.com and now back to me okay so
what's going on with the Democrats the
lefties the progressives and their media
cohorts before we get into the okay
there's the same group of people trying
to you know blaze a trail to a future
America let's talk about the crazies for
just a moment and when we do talk about
the crazies you've got to talk about the
crazies over at the televised mental
institution known as MSM you see here is
Chris Hayes who in my opinion I don't
mean this to be offensive or anything
the man looks like a muppet here is
Muppet man Chris Hayes he's very very
upset because here in Florida we are not
going to allow for genital mutilation of
children and this is very upsetting to
this human Muppet enjoy
now the sick irony here the one that I
just can't get over and really kind of
sticks with me
is that the right wing movement that
gave us this new law signed yesterday is
the very same group of people that
screamed about parental rights for years
amidst the pandemic I get to say whether
my kid wears a mask I get to say whether
my kid gets vaccinated I get to say
whether my kid goes to school
and Ron DeSantis was the public face of
that movement
that very same wing of the Republican
Party embodied by Ron DeSantis in the
government of the State of Florida
has now demanded and produced a
situation in which the government that
guy you saw there with the tough guy
Swagger about freedom is going to decide
if your child
who lives in your home
that you gave birth to or raised that
you love your kid what kind of care they
can get
he decides
care that to be clear the American
Academy of Pediatrics supports and
recommends
think about what this means that is what
the courage to be free means
Freedom means that in my household our
family decides what kind of Health Care
our child does or does not get
not Ron DeSantis not the Republican
party oh Muppet man let me clean this up
for you first off you and everyone that
watches MSNBC and all your network
cohorts and the entire Democrat Party
basically were four mandates you were
four kids being forced to be injected
with things whether it was with their
parents permission or not that's number
one so you're you're a complete
hypocrite but I get that hypocrisy is
dead in 2023. uh the other part of this
is we are talking about mutilating
children's genitals destroying their
god-given body okay and we know that
there is a social contagion element to
this meaning that suddenly it's not as
if suddenly out of nowhere uh that we
get all of these mostly girls that want
to transition to be boys there is a
social component it has something to do
with Tick Tock and the internet and
social pressures and all of these things
now we had a debate uh before we did the
show today because there was a picture
of a girl biological girl
who posted what her post-op meaning
post-trans surgery looks like and we had
a debate whether we were going to post
the picture and ultimately we decided
not to because it is so profoundly
upsetting and disturbing and everything
else that we didn't want to put up we
also thought that YouTube might just
take down the stream all together and
give the channel a strike so we did not
put it up but if you want to see what it
looks like when when a young girl a 15
year old girl gets the surgery what they
literally do is they take muscle tissue
and skin and they take that from her
thigh to create I mean this is just so
unbelievably awful to then create a
penis that is not a penis it does not
look like a penis it does not function
like a penis it has no sexual utility or
anything else if you want to see the
image that's going around the internet
right now Ashley Sinclair who I've had
on the show once or twice says she did
tweet it she put it up with a warning so
you actually have to click through the
warning to see it it's at Saint Claire
Ashley
s-t-c-l-a-i-r-a-s-h-l-e-y at Sinclair
Ashley if you want to see that image we
just decided not to put it up but that
these people are so for this is so
insane as if a 12 year old or a 13 year
old or a 15 year old who's a little
confused maybe about their sexuality or
their gender identity who's bludgeoned
by stuff online all the time and
activist teachers and all of these
things that they should be able their
brains which are not developed yet they
should be able to make a choice that
will impact them for the last rest of
their lives and that that Muppet man
gets up there pretending to have some
sort of moral Authority on this is so
insane what DeSantis is doing again this
is about kids once you become an adult
if you choose to mutilate your body or
whatever you choose to wear etc etc
that's up to you that is the policy of
Florida and by by the way that policy is
spreading throughout the country right
now and thank God it is and people like
Chris Hayes and all of these other
activists are there is going to be hell
to pay there is going to be quite a
comeuppance one day when these when when
a generation of young children who have
been mutilated and abused by medical
professionals and media professionals
and politics uh political professionals
uh when they realize what has happened
to their lives when you're a 25 year old
whose sex organs don't work who's
mutilated who doesn't actually look all
the way like a woman in many cases or
whatever it might be there is hell to
pay but it just continues guys I have a
warning for you we're going to have to
show you a clip from The View right now
Anna Navarro you know Anna Navarro she
lives near me she was once a
conservative a sane conservative I think
she was Marco Rubio's campaign she was
campaign manager if I'm not mistaken for
Marco Rubio Rubio definitely worked for
him she is now on the Sushi is
completely insane here she is lying
about Florida and Ron DeSantis surprise
surprise
is that um the the policies that um and
the positions that Rhonda Santos is
espousing are not traditional
conservative politics no he isn't right
Lisa Hutchinson would be right
absolutely but weaponizing government
against private business for exercising
their freedom of speech is not
conservative it is fascist it's also not
constitutional well and I think it's
part of wise numbers have dropped all
right first off the other lady I don't
even know her name oh no ASA Hutchinson
he's the real conservative because they
know that no one will support ASA
Hutchinson ASA Hutchinson is going to
get negative six votes so but ASA
Hutchinson is the he's like Chris
Christie he's so great ASA Hutchinson I
love h.i love that guy ASA Hutchinson
okay so that's one thing now as far as
uh as far as Anna Navarro
one more time guys and when I say one
more time I mean I'm gonna have to
repeat this a million more times
DeSantis took special rights away from
Disney you might argue that state and
corporate power combined would be a type
of fascism so it's almost as if fascism
existed with this relationship that
Disney had with the state of Florida and
DeSantis actually removed the fascism
okay that's really what happened here he
made it so that they have the same even
playing field as every other big uh
tourist attraction like gator world and
like Universal Studios and like Sea
World of course Disney should not have
special rights but with these people
fear more than anything else is
something's going on here guys dare I
quote Joe Biden I can't believe I'm
going to quote Joe Biden Rhonda santis
has a backbone like a ramrod and they're
freaking out about it that is exactly
what's going on here they cannot believe
that finally we have have a republican
politician who's doing the right thing
facing down the machine facing down his
opponents in the party out of the party
facing down the media the whole freaking
thing so across the board they're going
after him here is race huckster Al
Sharpton over the weekend this is at
Jordan Neely's funeral
and I captured as a minister deal with
this I heard the governor of Florida
DeSantis
say that the man that killed Jordan
Was a Good Samaritan
well and they've raised over two million
dollars for this man
[Applause]
well I know Governor DeSantis
that you put in black history and lgbtq
in Latino out of the school
but I have a Bible to put in the
governor's office
[Applause]
because apparently you don't know
what the Good Samaritan was
I should do a Al Sharpton impression
here but uh I yeah
I'll save it for a little bit later I'll
do it in the post game show uh because
we got a big show I got to keep up my
energy you understand uh look he is he
is the worst sort of race hux there if
there is a wound in America that this
guy can rip open and pour salt on he
will always find it as you guys know
Governor DeSantis did not ban black
history or anything related to LGBT
except you can't mutilate kids sorry and
certainly nothing but he mentions the
Hispanic Community what DeSantis did
related to Black History was there was
one AP course one AP African-American
studies course which was also going to
teach gender queer Theory so as I've
said many times unless you think that
the Underground Railroad was being run
by a lesbian and you think that would be
important to teach even if she was this
is completely ridiculous black people
like everyone else are flourishing in
Florida but don't tell that to the
NAACP you will not believe this one take
a look at this tweet I mean irony is
dead under the leadership of Governor
Ron DeSantis the State of Florida has
become hostile to Black Americans and in
direct conflict with the democratic
ideals that our Union was founded upon
that's naac president and CEO Derek from
NAACP there I don't even know his last
name Oh Derek Johnson uh Dara Johnson so
they're telling black people don't move
to Florida don't vacation in Florida now
Florida just closed up its biggest year
ever in terms of Tourism like breaking
every freaking record everyone's moving
down here you guys know the numbers 1200
people a day no one cares if you're
black or white frankly I think black
people much like white people like safe
cities they like nice weather they like
clean air they like nice infrastructure
uh things of that nature it's very
strange to think that humans actually
all want the same things but these race
hucksters are everywhere and they are
threatened because The Jig Is Up when it
comes to a guy like Rhonda Sanders he is
standing up to all the BS which is what
we've all wanted this entire freaking
time so here is uh
NAACP CEO Derek Johnson on CNN and he
doesn't care what any reality is about
Florida he wants to scare black people
it's regarding the national group's
notice to certain Travelers we have no
comment however on the economic
diversification front in just the last
few years Florida has moved into the
number one spot in the United States for
black owned businesses and number two
for Hispanic and number two for
women-owned businesses as well when you
hear those numbers what they are saying
is look African-Americans and Hispanics
are doing quite well here when it comes
to running their own businesses and
being able to make money here and being
able to live decent lives how do you how
do you address that with this new ban
first of all there's propaganda language
over the last several years it wasn't
because anything he did in policy flawed
by geography is an attractive place
where people would like to go reality is
propaganda language so there are more
black businesses in Florida than
anywhere second for Hispanics second for
women but that does not matter man you
got scary Ron DeSantis and we're going
to scare the hell out of everybody
it's such abject nonsense but they're
throwing in the kitchen sink uh we saw
this right before the show I thought
this was pretty spectacular the chairman
of the NAACP board of directors his name
is Leon Russell guess where he lives
Tampa Florida we've got to help that man
should we start a GoFundMe we will help
to get Leon Russell out of Florida
because it's bad for black people
chronic stupidity never ends let's talk
about CB Distillery and then we'll
continue with moronic stupidity and then
we get to the good stuff at the end
don't worry uh guys you know after I
tore my ACL I tried every solution there
was out of all the remedies CBD from CB
Distillery was incredibly helpful given
how much pain relief it brought to my
ACL and I'm playing ball again CB
Distillery has over 2 million satisfied
customers with 90 percent of them
reporting that they sleep better with
CBD 81 saying they have reduction in
stress thanks to their CBD and 80 of
them saying their aches and pains are
relieved from their CBD after physical
activity so if you struggle with sleep
stress pain or if you're just frustrated
with a health concern that's not getting
better try CBD from The Source I trust
cbdistillery.com let me get you on the
right path with the 20 discount visit
cbdistillery.com enter my name Dave for
your discount no prescription required
cbdistillery.com promo code Dave for 20
off and if you're looking at me right
now thinking Dave you look very
refreshed on this Monday I've been using
a little CBD before bed and sleeping
like a baby so there you go all right
let's continue uh because as you know
they are not going to let this Disney
thing go the entire left which used to
be anti-corporation right corporations
are mean Bernie Sanders they're not
paying their fair share we've got to
stop them they've got too much power
that was Jackie Mason but okay fine uh
they are not going to stop they are not
going to stop they love corporations now
and they hate that Ron DeSantis is
fighting Disney and Disney is struggling
by the way you know just think about it
this way if Rhonda says this was just
like some evil M effort right if he was
just some evil bastard like would he
would he be doing something that would
risk him losing some voters like it is a
risk it's working to his Advantage now
but when he when this fight started he
did not know which way this thing was
going to go now he ended up winning in a
massive Landslide and clearly culturally
in America most people are with him that
we've had it with the Disney nonsense
we've had it with the gender nonsense
and everything else we want kids to just
be kids
but he didn't know he didn't know if he
was going to lose voters especially in
the Orlando area Disney employs
something like 30 000 people if I'm not
mistaken it's crazy anyway we've got
some info here from The New York Times
because Disney is a struggling uh Disney
to close Star Wars themed hotel less
than two years after it opened the
planned closure of Galactic star Cruiser
an immersive role-playing attraction
comes as Disney seeks to cut overall
costs by more than 5 billion after
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
to build an immersive Star Wars themed
hotel at Walt Disney World Disney said
on Thursday that amid sweeping corporate
cost cutting it would close the
underperforming attraction in September
only about 18 months after it opened all
visits are two night stays with a
starting cost of more than four thousand
eight hundred dollars for two people and
around 6 000 for a family of four for
authenticity the hundred cabins at the
Florida hotel have no windows instead
stars planets and asteroid showers are
shown on video screens the announcement
came as Disney pulled the plug on plans
to build a one billion dollar office
complex in Orlando a decision said to be
influenced by the company's Feud with
Governor Ron DeSantis of Florida it was
also not long after Robert Iger in his
return as the company's chief executive
unveiled a corporate restructuring
intended to cut costs by 5.5 billion
okay real quick
I did not go to this Star Wars thing I'm
fairly certain that you guys know my
feelings on what Disney did to Star Wars
they have completely wrecked Star Wars
they have injected
wokism into all of their properties I
canceled Disney plus I know many of you
have canceled Disney plus but the whole
implication of that and also just the
idea putting aside whether you think
they didn't mess up Star Wars they did
mess up stars or anything else four
thousand eight hundred dollars for two
nights at a hotel with no windows what
level of Rich dork would you have to be
to be doing that six thousand dollars
for a family of four that is so
profoundly insane and think how how
Disney they're supposed to be pro-family
they hate families they hate families go
to Disneyland and see how expensive
everything is you know what I mean go to
Disneyland you can go to the other Star
Wars thing that'll remain open and I
think it's called Galaxy's Edge and to
build a lightsaber a piece of crap
plastic lightsaber that lights up and
will most likely be broken by the time
you get it to the car it's like 250
bucks the whole thing is a giant croc
but the New York Times is implying that
their struggles are desantis's fault
it's not the fault that they wrecked the
Star Wars lore it's not the uh it's not
that they uh giving you a hotel with no
windows and that they're caught charging
you six thousand dollars etc etc it's
all about run this Santa's well we've
got a tweet here from Florida's voice
desantis's office mocks Disney for
closing the Star Wars hotel which costs
families five five thousand plus Ron
DeSantis press secretary Jeremy Redfern
this entire story was just corporate
propaganda to distract from their failed
six thousand dollar two night Star Wars
Galactic star Cruiser experiment right
at the end of the day guys you know this
everyone knows this if that thing was
good if it was worthwhile if it was fun
if it was a good use of dollars families
would still be flocking there right but
it's just not what it was right you're
overpaying for crap and that's exactly
what Disney has become we saw this video
when we're putting the show together
this morning there is a guy online uh he
his channel is Mickey views what this
kid does kid he's a young man what he
does is he just spent his whole channel
is devoted to talking about what's going
on with Disney in terms of the rides the
movies the business behind it and all
that and he made a great point that uh
this move by Disney to close this thing
has very little to do with the
scientists it's too costly they're
having major relocation issues and Bob
Iger the new guy who just took over
who's the old guy uh well that he hated
it fairly interesting wouldn't you say
okay so there you go but let's continue
because the machine the machine does not
stop we're gonna have to show somebody
no we're not going to show a video of
someone from The View again but we are
going to read a tweet from someone of
the view again should we put the warning
up on that on a tweet have we ever done
that before let's do it because I just
want to warn people apparently it's not
a clip just bear with us people it's a
it's a tweet from a certifiably crazy
person you know this Alyssa Farah trick
so this is the girl who pretends to be a
conservative on The View and you know
they sort of like half-assedly pretend
that they like her but they'll wreck her
one day when they need to get rid of her
that's how it is she tweeted this out
about the uh the Disney situation she
wrote the development deal Disney pulled
the plug on would have created 2 000 new
jobs with an average salary of 120 a
year the median household income in
Florida is about 60
000. well okay how about now before we
continue we show you the video from uh
Mickey views here is Mickey views the
the guy who runs the channel That I just
mentioned he specializes in Disney and
their businesses well he's completely
debunking her
second breaking Disney news update I
have for you guys is Parks chairman Josh
tomorrow finally releasing a statement
that I think we've been expecting for a
while here regarding the Lake Nona
project Disney is officially abandoning
the project for those of you who don't
know the Lake Nona project was previous
CEO Bob chapek's plan to build a new
Disney headquarters inside of Florida in
Lake Nona a very nice planned community
that is up and coming that you have near
the airport in Orlando it's a beautiful
area we made a video here on the channel
about two years ago taking a look at
where this office was going to go the
land that Disney acquired the media is
spinning this cancellation as being due
to DeSantis and the Hostile business
environment which he helped to create
with Disney the reason I'm skeptical
that DeSantis really had so much to do
with this cancellation is because you
know we know people in high places you
guys have seen some of the stories we've
broken here on the channel in the past
I've been hearing for months that this
is just a Apec error project that Iger
wants nothing to do with look at how
fast all these jpeg air projects are
just crumbling turning to dust you know
the reality is that Disney has huge
bills coming due on the streaming side
they're having issues on the earning
side of things paying to build a big new
campus a big new headquarters in Florida
making people move from California which
is very unpopular internally and part of
why chapeck was so unpopular inside the
company eiger's wiping his hands clean
of this whole thing okay guys so you
really need to understand here without
without getting too much into the
minutia of this that the way the media
is covering this that this is fully
desantis's fault that they're losing
business and losing some jobs is just
complete nonsense Disney's having all
sorts of problems because of its crappy
product but it's not just because of its
crappy product it's because it went whoa
you remember months ago when we were
playing those videos day after day of
the diversity Equity inclusion
Department in Disney talking about how
they have their secret gay agenda and
they want boys to be girls and that one
woman who's in charge of programming
she's got a binary daughter and a
two-spirit son and a three penis goat or
whatever it is it's like it never stops
with these people and people have had
enough you like the three painters go
that was
um I don't know that's what she said I'm
pretty sure we'd have to check the
record anyway the point is their crappy
product and their wokeness is what is
destroying them and then the fact that
Bob chapic the former CEO who was
sitting there remember in that struggle
session he's sitting there as the bunch
of them are lecturing him on how he
needs to be better he then got canned
and they brought in Bob Iger and then
Bob Iger who was the former CEO of
Disney before he looks at the numbers he
looks at the papers he's a businessman
who's done quite well with Disney over
the years and he goes okay we're
building this billion dollar campus well
we're urging money so we're not going to
do that and we're going to fix a whole
bunch of this stuff so this is what
businesses do in in the free market uh
Giancarlo Sopo from Vista media Visto
media tweeted this uh the truth is this
project died the day chapik was fired
Iger hated it it was a terrible idea and
it had already been delayed until 2026.
those 2000 jobs were California
transplants mostly of whom did not want
to move to Florida because creatives
like La this article car uh called it in
November so back in November uh wow news
today which focuses on Disney had that
anyway let's get back to uh Alyssa Ferry
you'll see what we're doing here trust
me Alyssa Farah from The View saw that
from Giancarlo and she wrote This I
Believe Giancarlo is correct here but
the political problem is public
perception the governor picked a fight
and the State lost jobs and revenue she
continued having a major corporation
come out and say they left your state
because of the uncertain business
environment is a huge blow when one of
the biggest selling points on the right
is about the free state of Florida has
been about the free state of Florida has
been the business environment so you
have to understand here she's doing
exactly what everyone in corporate media
does she's lying about what the real
issue is it's not that Disney is not
friendly to business that Florida is not
friendly to business Florida started
taking away Disney's special rights so
if other states want to give certain
corporations special right which
actually seems anti-constitutional to me
they can go ahead and do it but Florida
is going to have a even playing field
for everybody I don't like to do this
sort of thing but every now and again I
have to dunk on somebody a slam dunkaroo
on the Twitter and I saw Alyssa's tweet
and I tweeted this
to Alyssa I retweeted her I said what
makes you a conservative or a republican
other than it pays well to pretend to be
one to be on The View DeSantis took
special rights away from Disney he got
rid of crony capitalism oh wait Disney
owns ABC which just so happens to be the
network you work for Whoopi enjoy we'll
trash the hell out of you once you're
fired right after the election by the
way hope it's worth it uh and of course
I followed up Alyssa Faris shuts off the
replies on her tweet so you're not
allowed to reply to her Alyssa it's
really not worth it have some
self-respect ask Megan McCain if she's
happier now you know I really do try not
to get into these little Twitter battles
but these people
I do it with corporate people if you're
a corporate mainstream hack then I will
go after you I try not to do it
generally speaking it's not like the
best use of time to be fighting with
people on Twitter but do you think it's
odd that she works at ABC Disney and
she's taking the position she is as a
conservative so the question now let's
get back to the top of the show the
question is what is a conservative what
it what is it that we are trying to
conserve why are all of these Disney
corporate chills attacking DeSantis
right why is
Alyssa Farah going after her Anna
Navarro who also works at ABC Disney the
Litany of people why are they doing it
well I think there's a reason they're
doing it and now we're going to get into
that uh Marcel Tulum who's the director
of students for DeSantis had a good
tweet on this uh just laying it out
pretty cleanly Republicans who have
actively sided with Disney in their Pro
grooming pro-child mutilation battle
against Ron DeSantis Donald Trump yes
he's been Pro Disney Mike Pence you
we've played that clip many many times
he he doesn't like what DeSantis is
doing against Disney Nikki Haley
welcomed Disney to South Carolina ASA
Hutchinson nobody's paying attention to
him we don't have to waste any time
Chris Christie he doesn't like that
DeSantis is using the rule of law and
Vivek ramaswami has repeatedly gone
after DeSantis all again for taking away
special rights of a corporation so it is
the same line of attack that Alyssa
Farah and what I would say I don't think
I've if we would go back in the history
of the show I don't know how many times
I've said the phrase Rhino I don't
really like that phrase because it
shrinks the pool right Republican in
name only but these people are rhinos
they are they will not conserve anything
they will not defend anything's good and
then when someone gets out there and
this is the key part when someone gets
out there in this case it happens to be
the scientist and stands up for the
right thing we would prefer you not uh
chop the generals off children okay
would that be okay guys they try to
destroy him so you must understand they
are Shilling for special interests for
corporations instead of free markets and
Free People and free children
here's video a former vice president
Mike Pence siding with Disney
I just don't believe it's it's in the
interest of the people of any state for
a a government to essentially go after a
business that they disagreed with on a
political issue I disagree with Florida
moving against uh Walt Disney I disagree
with California moving against Walgreens
because they're going to obey the law
about a board of patients in some 20
States so they're going to cancel 120
million dollar project look at the end
of the day the business of America is
business and and I'm not terribly
surprised to see Disney canceling a
billion dollar contract it's only that's
only going to harm people in the Orlando
and Florida area and and it's that one
more reason why uh as a limited
government conservative uh I've said for
months now that I I think both sides
ought to stand down
all right I think you know my feelings
on this I mean as a limited government
conservative meaning that you think the
government has no role in anything if
the RO if the governments have a role in
anything it would be to keep an even
playing field so that businesses could
operate in an even way and let the best
businesses the best products the hardest
working people win what Pence is saying
is I I wish DeSantis wouldn't have done
anything Disney should have kept their
special rights their special tax tax
exemptions their special corporate
Kingdom they should be treated specially
and somehow that is the position of the
conservative it's just complete nonsense
but it continues here's Nikki Haley
siding with Disney
what is your reaction to that as we
still have yet to see him jump
officially into the race
you know as Governor I took a
double-digit unemployment state and I
turned it into an economic Powerhouse
businesses were my partners because if
you take care of your businesses you
take care of your economy your economy
takes care of the people and everyone
wins and so that's the way we dealt with
it we are South Carolina was a very
anti-woke state it still is and if
Disney would like to move their hundreds
of thousands of jobs to South Carolina
and bring the billions of dollars with
them I'll let them know I'll be happy to
meet them in South Carolina and
introduce them to the governor and the
legislature that would that would
welcome it all right I just want to say
on a personal note I really like Nikki
I've interviewed her a few times we've
had dinner together so I genuinely Nikki
if you're watching this I mean this with
love you got this one wrong what are you
saying that you would give special
benefits to Disney if they moved to
South Carolina because all DeSantis is
doing is making sure they're treated
like everybody else so if you're
interested in crony capitalism or what
some might call fascism then I guess you
should do that but come on you everyone
knows like The Jig Is up everyone sees
what's going on here everyone is afraid
of DeSantis right now whether it's Trump
or Nikki Haley or anyone else and what
they're really afraid of is oh my god
there finally is a republican doing the
right thing and he's doing it while
being unencumbered by what his opponents
and the media says and everything else
but it continues here's ASA Hutchinson
who's going to get negative six votes
but he's also with Disney
as a small government conservative which
you just repeated here what's your take
on leaders in your party Ron DeSantis
among them who are actively using the
government to change social policy and
wage culture wars well let's be more
specific about Disney I don't like what
Disney said about the legislation that I
would have supported in Florida but it's
not the role of government to punish a
business when you disagree with what
they're saying or a position that they
take if that was the view of a
republican then we're going to be in all
kinds of trouble in our businesses in
blue States if they start punishing
businesses for taking a more
conservative speech or position and so I
don't understand a conservative
punishing a business that's the largest
employer in the state in Arkansas and as
Governors we recruit industry we support
our industry because it provides jobs do
I even have to bother like you got it
right like come on dude it's so obvious
here's
riding with Disney
when you look at someone like Ron
DeSantis in Florida I mean you have been
obviously very critical of him you've
called him a career politician and you
said he's deeply insecure but isn't he
implementing a lot of these principles
that you have been advocating for to a
limited extent but I think that the
problem is what we really need in the
White House is a leader not a follower
and when you're off by half you get
things wrong I mean just look at the way
that Disney has managed to outsmart Ron
DeSantis because when you're going
through the motions and you're doing it
for the reason of getting a nice little
bump on Twitter or nice cycle of media
you're not actually solving the problem
that you set out to solve vivec I like
you dude I really do we've hung out a
couple of times you've been on the show
but what the f are you talking about
DeSantis is leading not following your
following because you're doing exactly
what Mike Pence and Nikki Haley and ASA
Hutchinson and Johnson
and all of these other people are doing
it's just nonsense but you want more
followers well now Chris Christie is
going to get involved that's what
they're saying New York Post Chris
Christie to announce presidential run in
the coming days and as far as running
well
you got the joke here's Chris Christie
siding with Disney
I don't think Rob DeSantis is a
conservative based on his actions
towards Disney I mean you know where are
we headed here now
um that if you express this agreement in
this country the the government is
allowed to punish you
to me that's what I always thought
liberals did
and now all of a sudden here we are
participating in this with a republican
governor and
what you really need to understand so I
don't have to keep repeating myself with
this is all of these guys will be loved
by the media the more they go after
DeSantis the one guy who is doing what
we the people want the more that they
will get air time that they will be oh
they're the real choice on The View we
like that ASA Hutchinson we like Chris
Christie and what they mean by that is
you are ineffectual you are unable to
win and you will never accomplish
anything but it even continues Donald
Trump over the weekend on Truth social
the Sanctus is being absolutely
destroyed by Disney his original PR
planned fizzled so now he's going back
with a new one in order to save face
Disney's next move will be the
announcement that no more money will be
invested in Florida because of the
governor in fact they could even
announce a slow withdrawal or sale of
certain Properties or the whole thing
watch that would be a killer in the
meantime this is also unnecessary a
political stunt Ron should work on the
squatter mess okay first off I don't
know what he's talking about with the
squatter mess and Florida is by far the
freest economic and and political and
cultural state to live in that's one
thing the Sanctus okay that's just more
name-calling meaningless Trump but
interestingly Trump is taking the side
of the walksters he's taking the side of
the giant corporations he's taking the
side of special interest and special
treatment and he's taking the sight of
the people who want to chop genitals off
kids that seems a little bizarre to me
as Trump was supposed to be the one that
was uh you know he was supposed to be
the chosen one to destroy all of them
any who whether we're talking Trump or
Hutchinson or Chris Christie or Nikki
Haley or Mike Pence or vivec et cetera
Etc you can see it guys they are all
focused on one guy so uh let's just play
a little video of what this one guy
happens to think of those guys
I just think as as conservatives you
know it's not conservative to just
simply defer to every corporation in
America that's being a corporatist and
so when I have to when I have to look
and see in the State of Florida you know
are we being governed appropriately are
we advancing the rule of law and I have
to take on a company like Disney you
know a corporatist would say that you
have to give Disney Everything at Once
well in reality uh Disney was enjoying
unprecedented privileges and subsidies
they controlled their own government in
Central Florida they were exempt from
laws that virtually everybody else had
to follow they had great tax breaks they
were even able to rack up debt no single
entity or individual in the State of
Florida enjoyed such privileges and you
know that's not good government that's
not free enterprise but it's certainly
even worse when a company takes all
those privileges that have been bestowed
over many many decades and uses that to
wage war on state policy regarding
families and children so we said that
Arrangement doesn't work for us that
self-governing status is gone and that's
exactly what we did if you're a
corporatist you would not want to
counteract that because you would let
them do whatever they want but if you're
somebody that believes that we the
people ultimately govern and that we
should have a rule of law and a free
enterprise means uh actually everybody
follows the same set of rules than what
Florida's doing is exactly and precisely
correct and we're going to continue to
do what is correct
guys I'm sorry I don't think I can
overstate it this is the chance we have
to save America it really is it really
is look my my life has been enriched by
the policies that this guy has put forth
but this is now Ground Zero for Freedom
not only in America and in the world and
if you don't see that Stark Stark
difference between the way DeSantis
wants to govern and the way the rest of
these guys want to govern then well I
know you do because you're watching this
show so I guess you might know somebody
who doesn't see it and our our work is
to is to con is to continue to convert
those people but this guy and this
energy and this message is the future
Prof proper governance when it is
effective when it is necessary
government shouldn't run everything but
it should also do nothing unless you're
a complete Anarchist and if you're a
complete Anarchist then so be it I think
actually if you're a complete Anarchist
you would at least be more principled
than the rest of these guys who were
running uh for office but just remember
everyone's attacking DeSantis right now
nobody's attacking Trump why isn't
Hutchinson attacking Trump why isn't
Chris Christie attacking Trump why isn't
vivec attacking Trump
well it's fairly obvious because
DeSantis actually is the leader at this
point like just trust me on this that
it's just so freaking obvious uh here's
a tweet from Florida's voice here's what
Trump's doing Trump New York's Andrew
Cuomo did better than DeSantis on covet
debts really think the level of the
lying that is coming out of trump right
now yes somehow Cuomo who killed all of
the old people putting them back into
the
Elderly Homes that he did better than
Florida Florida with the second oldest
population and DeSantis fought to keep
it open and that's why a million people
have moved here and all of the stuff
absolute lies but don't take my word for
it here's Trump acknowledging that the
Santos was doing right by covid
as many pools and school districts are
closing across the country Florida
Governor Rhonda
Rhonda's in May
um saying that many kids are not
vulnerable to this disease do you agree
with that assessment and do you believe
that schools would you recommend that
schools open up and to those states that
have well I have a lot of confidence in
Ron DeSantis a lot of faith in Ron
DeSantis to make the right decision he's
doing a great job as Governor Ron
DeSantis I I had read where he's
thinking about opening up the schools
earlier than the date the end of the
month uh I'd have to look at the numbers
all right so there is reality and then
there's just lies so I get it and I know
a lot of trump people are angry at me
for just playing what Donald Trump's own
words are but when he attacks Florida
when he attacks the covid response when
he now is defending Disney over Florida
and over to Santa's it's just absolutely
ridiculous and let's not forget Not only
was Trump for warp speed he was for
locking down the country and I grant
everybody a leash a certain leash on it
but you can't forget it Trump's base is
the most anti-lockdown anti-man mandate
people there are but Trump was the
president when it all happened
we did the right thing we closed the
country down could have kept it open and
I could have done what some countries
are doing I had to shut it down we did
the right thing I thought of keeping it
open and we did just the right thing we
closed it down and a group of very smart
people walk in and say sir we have to
close it
and we did the right thing they can't do
anything without the approval of the
president of the United States even the
Democrats aren't blaming me for that we
had to close it up some people wish we
never closed it down we did the right
thing we closed it it's a decision for
the president of the United States we
did the right thing we had to close it
up because nobody's ever heard of
closing down a country let alone the
United States of America we had to turn
off the airlines we had to turn off
everything
and we did the right thing a lot of
people have thought about it write it
out don't do anything just write it out
and think of it as the flu
but it's not the truth it's vicious we
basically shut down our country you know
we did the right thing we had to close
it down the president of the United
States calls the shots and we had to
close it down we did the right things
they're not working in offices they're
not in airplanes together and we did
close up we had to close it up and we
did the right thing we closed it down we
did the right thing we closed it up we
were told we got to shut it down stop it
tell everyone to stay home
because of this horrible virus and we
did that we had to artificially close
our country we've done this right and we
we really we really have done this right
that we did the right everything we did
was right all right look guys hindsight
is 20 20. and again I grant everybody a
Long Leash and I happen to pick on up on
it very early if you go back to the
videos you know 15 days to slow the
spread on day 16 I started freaking out
and then the rest is history and I ended
up moving 3000 miles away right
okay so be it I grant Trump a certain
window on this thing uh but the
interesting thing is has Trump ever said
I regret it I regret closing everything
down and that it wasn't maybe the duty
of the president it was the duty of the
states like where is your Maya culpa on
this because your base the people who
are the most angry at me for pointing
this out are the most anti-lockdown
people so where where is that video of
him saying boy you know I did screw that
up I shouldn't have listened to fauci
and it was not my job to do it in the
first place and all of that stuff but
you get it you know that's not coming
he's still proud of operation warp speed
the fact that we rushed through getting
these mRNA vaccines into people's arms
and now we have all this stuff with
vaccine injuries and everything else so
the question you have to ask going
forward is if you're on the fence about
who to vote for do you think he would do
it again well if he's shown No Remorse
in what's gone on with lockdowns or with
vaccines then I suspect the answer is
yes uh and DeSantis is taking a very
very different approach on how we would
do anything when it comes to all this in
the future
we also signed the most robust medical
Freedom legislation anywhere in the
United States not only did we codify all
our protections against covet
authoritarianism we expanded it so that
no private or public sector vax mandates
on not just covet vaccines any vacs
under emergency use or mnra that is your
choice and they should not deny you the
right to work based on that choice
we made sure they can't mandate it on
school children and that parents are
ultimately the ones that make that
determination the way they weaponized
these covid vaccines was a massive
incursion into our freedoms they wanted
to deny people the right to put food on
their table if they didn't bend the knee
and get a coveted shot that they may not
have wanted and that many of them did
not need we can never allow warp speed
to Trump informed consent in this
country ever again
look guys the the question going forward
when it comes to this election will be
who do you think will stand up to the
machine again will it be any of the
people that I've been talking about here
and showing these videos who are afraid
to stand up to Disney and are taking the
sides of giant corporations say giant
pharmaceutical companies etc etc or it
will be the guy who has a track record
now of doing it standing up to
corporations signing all of the
legislation to make sure that big farmer
will not dictate what you put in your
body etc etc
like I think the answer is fairly
obvious to Santa's thinks the answer is
fairly obvious too
it's easy to be a front runner it's easy
to go out and take positions that are
really popular at the time it's harder
to dig in and really cut Against the
Grain but not going to be easy but I
honestly believe that uh that we have an
opportunity to right the ship and to get
this whole country going wouldn't it be
something if we ride at the ship I
really think we can do it I think this
is the great chance this is America's
chance this is America's comeback
opportunity we could right the ship with
decent leadership that stands up for the
right things now the machine is going to
genuflect and go bananas and scream and
yell and they're going to make it seem
like Rhonda santis is 10 times worse
than Donald Trump that's what they are
going to do and you can see everyone
lining up against him
but this is the chance this simply is
the chance and you know what happens
when you when you stick your neck out
and when you lead as opposed to what
Vivek said as if DeSantis is following
he's following you know what happens
when you lead people start getting
braver right I talk about this all the
time when you model it for somebody oh
you stood up and did the right thing you
stood up with your shoulders back you
said what you believed you fought for
something that was honest and true then
other people start doing it and it's
exactly what's happened here in Florida
another one from Florida's Voice new
Florida Republicans have expanded their
lead over State Democrats to more than
000 voters uh by the way what's
interesting about this guys is that in
2018 right around when DeSantis took
office the Democrats had an advantage of
a hundred thousand registered voters now
it is 470 to the Republicans so if you
do the right thing
if you lead people to the promised land
a couple people are going to follow some
people will complain about it and some
people will drown in the Red Sea but it
is what it is uh I've enjoyed this show
Brock I think you were right what do you
call
you called a 9-8 I'm calling it it's a
nine eight people we did it happy Monday
to you we got a post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com uh in about 37
seconds we leave you with cringe
Jean-Pierre tattoo
president is the best Communicator that
we have in the White House and and Joan
Shin Gangnam Style
let the rock tell you in Chinese
[Music]
thank you